imprenable sur la roche de solutré et
une table gastronomique en plein air au
coeur du vignoble mâconnais ce concept
oenotouristique unique en bourgogne
c'est un jeune viticulteur camille
paquet qui en a eu l'idée
avec mon frère on est travaillé ici et
et on se dit il faut qu'on exploite la
chose parce qu on a une vue qui est
magnifique un petit clos 12 ares de
vignes faut vraiment qu'on en fasse
quelque chose et la première haie
d'essai était d'inviter nos clients et
nos amis nos plus gros clients bordelais
américain et c'est qu'ils ont trouvé le
spot incroyable donc là pour l'apéro
vous avez vous géré au fromage cake aux
olives impôts demolon et puis la
charcuterie un repas concocté à base de
produits du terroir et servi par gilles
bérard chef d'un restaurant à mâcon
cette table au milieu des vignes c'était
un projet qui lui tenait à coeur
et lorsque camille paquet lui a proposé
de venir voir le clos des carrats il a
immédiatement été conquis au mois de
décembre les montées avec mon épouse
et puis on a vu cette parcelle en un
troussage génial et on s'est dit ok et
en fait les premières tables 7 au mois
d'avril afin de proposer un service de
restauration en pleine nature
gilles bérard cuisine exclusivement à la
plancha alimentée au gaz
il a dû s'organiser méthodiquement pour
respecter les normes d'hygiène et de
conservation des aliments
je demande aux convives de choisir le
menu 48 heures avant et c'est un menu
unique pour toute la table comme ça j'ai
pas plusieurs produits qui se baladent à
droite à gauche c'est une entrée un plat
fromage s'ils le souhaitent et dessert
tout est préparé le matin même dans le
restaurant ensuite s'est mis en plaques
film est datée et une demi-heure avant
de monter je charge la camionnette et
c'est dans les cas si sauter et le
succès est au rendez-vous tous les
vendredis et samedis sont réservés pour
juillet août
mais il reste encore les jours en
semaine à condition bien sûr
qu'il fasse
merci on est criant un break d'une
nation qui je trouve